so what did film school teach you about
working with actors what were some of
the core principles they instilled you
know I think from the first level it's
auditions in just how technical and you
know what an important role they can
play in in the film in terms of even
sculpting you know what the movie is
going to be I mean it's it's interesting
you know I mean I guess people sometimes
refer to casting as part of the writing
process for the movie but I usually
people say you know it's the writing
it's the production and then the editing
that are kind of the three writing
stages of a movie but certainly ed the
casting gets thrown in there and
especially on movies the sort of
productions I've done is because you're
starting to yeah you know bring the
characters to life you actually see if
it's gonna work in these auditions often
you know you sometimes usually sometimes
you don't know whether the materials any
good and and you know for in for this
movie it was you know the script was
built a lot off of the auditions and so
I think having that sort of comfort of
what you want to get out of an audition
is is is you know a huge value for for a
movie and and so yeah that's part of it
you know I think at film school you I
suppose learn to take him seriously I
don't know if that's the right idea but
yeah you there's i would say i learned a
technique for audition that didn't you
sculpt over you know a bunch of
auditions and and to the point where you
know you look forward to that process
now so i think it kind of starts there
because you know auditions are
essentially you're directing actors to
try to see if they can give you a
performance that you then
want to capture so you know you're
you're directing throughout auditions
you know in Lisa's the far as far as I
kind of was Todd or you know took the
process that I like to be so I do think
about it even from that first step of
you know what are the direction what are
the changes in someone's performance
that you want to see and how do you tell
them that verbally how do you
communicate that to them and so it's
learning a lot about the language of
speaking to someone to get that out of
them you know
you